bonjour tout le monde ça va bon vous
connaissez le chemin la partie
pour ce faire jouer
qui a payé sept personnages et pour
l'instant je voudrais qu'il y en ait au
moins deux qu'ils fassent un storyboard
et ensuite les autres vous allait
retravailler votre personnage ce que
vous avez là où vous avez fait vous
allez en choisir un et vous allez leur
travail au propre
on va le mettre en couleur man c'est à
dire l'homme serpent il l'a beaucoup vu
qu'il est là il a des super pouvoirs
pillay c'est comme spider man il a été
piquée par un serpent
du coup il peut voir ce qui se passe au
loin et qui me plaît c'est bah c'est
d'inventer et dessiner c'est une machine
à voyager dans le temps
[Musique]
je n'aime pas beaucoup de clés au départ
en fait
je les laisse développer leur propre
univers avec leurs propres sources
d'inspiration ce qu'ils ont envie de
dire et ensuite à partir de là je vais
vérifier si vraiment on comprend ce
qu'il veut le faire et je vérifie s'il
ya une logique dans ce qu'ils ont fait
mais ça va être lors une logique qui
correspond à leur univers alors si le
dessin j'arrive pas à tout comprendre
ouais d'accord est ok c'est un
personnage et dans le futur c'est le
drame du futur en septième il aya une
voiture celle là qui va en fait détruire
l'environnement alors pour sauver les
balles et leurs amis du futur et va les
vacances aux machines pour aller
chercher toutes les autres craignent et
d'une passé
[Musique]
leur fait faire de la bande dessinée ou
du dessin comme si c'est dans une école
de décembre professionnel adapté à leur
âge parce que ils ont le disant mais
c'est à dire que je leur fait comprendre
que le dessin et se pratique en étant
concentré en étant attentif en étant un
peu persévérant aussi un pas
systématiquement arrêtés parce que c'est
trop difficile à refaire un petit peu
petit à petit on finit par y arriver
[Musique]
elle veut plus et ce n'est qu'à
l'arrivée puis regardez
bois des centres fermés c'est la propre
femme propos comme et surtout pompiers
au tableau sûr comme je fais
[Musique]